بعد عده ساعات على بدء العمليه العسكريه
لجيش الاحتلال هنا في هذه المنطقه بدات
بالفعل عمليه الانسحاب من داخل المخيم
وهنا جيب عسكري تم اعطاب بفعل العمليه او
بفعل عبوه ناسفه وايضا هناك صوره لاليه او
لمركبه تم سحبها بفعل ايضا اثناء هذه
العمليه العسكريه بالفعل انتهت العمليه
العسكريه على ما يبدو وبدء بالفعل الانس
الحب الجزئي من داخل مخيم الفارعه الى
الجنوب من محافظه طوباس في هذه اللحظات
نرصد هنا ايضا تحرك للاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه التي لا تزال او بدات بالفعل
بالخروج من داخل المخيم على وقع ذلك كان
هناك عده اصابات داخل هذا المخيم نعم اذا
بالفعل انسحبت اليات الاحتلال العسكريه من
داخل المخيم ما يزيد عن 25 اليه عسكريه
اقتحمت المخيم برفقه جرافه وفي هذه
اللحظات انسحبت هذه الاليات وخلف هذا
الاقتحام عددا من الاصابات تم نقلهم الى
المستشفى التركي في محافظه طوباس من مخيم
الفارعه ليث جعار
الجزيره